thank you
so maybe some of you guys you know a
thing or two about fighting can solve
this mystery I'll answer this one David
could do it because he's good at beating
people up here's something all right
crucifix
imagine Anthony was the one that's like
the killer in the room that's impossible
how is that even a funny joke how's that
even a bit impossible imagine the part
where we actually
started the news wouldn't it be funny if
Anthony was like the cool one yeah he is
he is he's look at his hair look how
cool would you have a beer you're purple
huh hey guess what I have a liver issue
and I'm gonna die in a few years can you
die quicker yeah be quick buddy thank
you for the Korean with that Korean ass
hurt you [ __ ] [ __ ] anyway let's go huh
let's do it hey Mom you hear my feeling
what is purple kinda
up
holding my breath for an hour
we're gonna turn Anthony dude your hair
is amazing I think so too it looks like
Japanese [ __ ] here let's go appreciate
it I could tell that's like you know so
there's a youth basketball game right oh
that's good and then there's a fight
that broke out here we go
and I've lost the freaking page hold on
a fight breaks out the refs are trying
to do what they can to stop it and for
some freaking reason this one ref is in
the middle of a scuffle and then he just
turns and runs across the court and just
decks a totally different dude that's
nice you got to do the heights let's see
what I mean someone called him a [ __ ]
that's why he probably had music playing
in his head a high school wreck yeah bro
and then we'll show you guys if we need
we gotta hear what the music sounds like
later so yeah watch this oh yeah I did
run oh is that a teacher a parent just
knocked out another parent oh that other
person just flopped though oh that guy's
might have been talking [ __ ] the whole
game probably because some dads are
[ __ ] like that man
oh wait can we watch that again yeah
yeah I'm muted because it's yeah he's
one of those [ __ ] [ __ ] talking dads
man so look at this yeah so he goes and
runs across boom and just knocks hey
that's how people die though bro getting
laid out by a Foot Locker employee is
the funniest thing in the world
let me see your shoe size taking it off
here David because you may not you're
probably not able to see it so he this
guy right here he's in the middle of
that fight runs over yo can I say
something real quick this is actually
the type of videos I watch at night
before I go to sleep I love them this is
my favorite favorite thing to watch just
because it's a quick reality check for
people like fighting is dangerous it is
man and there's so many people who talk
big and they talk [ __ ] right I do that
all the time I would never all right
like like if this is happening and
somebody's running at me I'm not sitting
there turning my back you you face that
person you see what's up because if
you're gonna talk that [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this will happen favorite thing hey do
yourself a favor YouTube 808 scraps I
love them 808 scraps is the best thing
on earth in Hawaii you want big you want
beer all right let's go put my slippers
if you ever want to watch into a state
or an area where everybody's MMA fighter
go to Hawaii for real it is not fair
like some people just start talking [ __ ]
and the guy starts taking off his shoes
in the streets I'm like well now you're
gonna get hit yo there's like high
school kids [ __ ] doing some straight
up kickboxing it's amazing and they know
how to throw [ __ ] roundhouses and
[ __ ] and I'm like damn dude the first
time I ever went to Hawaii I was at a
bar with our buddy Sam
and this guy I didn't know this slime
but he was like what's up bro you want
beef bro take this outside bro you want
beef I'm like damn people about to cook
some good [ __ ]
start scrapping Haymakers God God
[ __ ] knocks the dude out everybody's
screaming he picks him up takes him to
the bar buys him a beard he goes we good
he goes we good and they just start
drinking again
they were like six foot three and like
maybe well the other guy was like my
height but they're [ __ ] yoke they're
actually but they have muscles and they
were just wailing on each other dude it
was [ __ ] crazy
Hawaii is amazing it's the best place on
Earth I can't wait till we open up there
if a Simone dude complains he's getting
his drinks for friends you want beef
broth no but you want drinks he's like
you want beef rice balls only in the
form of kyleby because they have them
but you know what when you guys play
basketball I don't know if when's the
last time you guys played ball I well I
know basketball games
they get [ __ ] eat it the old the
closest times I've ever been in like a
fight outside of a gym is when like
someone on the basketball court tries to
like start some [ __ ] the coach I call
him the coach you're the guy that's the
worst player on the course Jason Chen
[ __ ] that [ __ ] son of a [ __ ]
no that's so true though I I almost
[ __ ] choke that [ __ ] out for
playing the way that he does why how
does he play so he he does he does all
these no look passes right and then he
he throws the ball like this far away
expects you to [ __ ] die for it and he
gets so mad when you don't [ __ ] go
for it he doesn't know look passes
because we can't see him because he's so
short that's that's true he's like no he
was actually looking at you Jason Jason
so just to just to put it in the right
frame Jason she's actually really good
at basketball
he's [ __ ] dope dude that little five
foot one little girl can [ __ ] ball
and he gets pissed at everybody the
problem with him is that when we play
ball we don't give a [ __ ] we're just
having fun there's no competition
everybody can play this [ __ ]
clothesline me once it's just it's just
[ __ ] I didn't even know we were
playing basketball it's just [ __ ] fun
right so one time
um Ed Park so we used to go into uh
Whittier the high school because my
buddy Khalif was the coach at the time
and after school he would let us go play
with him so we would just be we would
have a court to ourselves so Ed Park
doesn't play basketball so when you have
somebody who doesn't play the sport you
kind of just play to their level because
if we're just trying to have fun and Ed
is already kind of shy about it he
doesn't want to come out but I convinced
him to come out I was like Hey we're
just here to have fun then Jason starts
yelling at Ed like what the [ __ ] are you
dumb you don't know how to [ __ ] play
oh that's why I come for Jason and you
know Jason doesn't dig up like that but
in basketball he's very he's a different
person in basketball yeah really so I
I'm like listening to this and I already
don't like it when he's doing this to Ed
because Ed came out and he didn't want
to come out and we kind of convinced him
that just because we'll have fun and so
it's like what the [ __ ] man I didn't
know I was gonna go [ __ ] cook for
Gordon Ramsay today
[ __ ] play ball you [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then it gets super dead silent and
afterwards I'm going to drink water at
the water fountain he just comes up he
goes
I apologize
it's like [ __ ] what are you yelling at
this guy for but he gets hyper
competitive a lot of like Streetball
players play like they're going into the
[ __ ] NBA it looks like your [ __ ]
legs out too I've always gotten two
fights at LA Fitness yeah bro because
when I I'm not good at shooting but I'm
good at defense because I wonder why I
wonder
so that's happened
in and then it always started some issue
they get so pissed off and I just be
like stop being a [ __ ] and get through
me what the [ __ ] Nick loves basketball
dude that's like his [ __ ] dude David
playing it down David all like his knees
all batting and [ __ ]
and he's all bented
my Meniscus first and then I shoot why
is it that all Ballers like they like
set up all pigeon toe like this it must
have been the technique because none of
us not a playback is that a good
technique because they probably saw a
couple Ballers on TV do it and tried to
replicate because a curtsy is the
perfect downward move that you're gonna
do before you toss so this is why this
is why I do it so when you shoot right
yeah so you know typically when you're
Scott you're supposed to put your legs
out this way yeah this right here is
inefficient with typing all you need is
to bring it in so you could quickly oh
when you do this this is way more time
Fools versus this that wow stop doing
that meniscus
you guys still play at the park oh my
god dude now we don't even train anymore
we don't do nothing you just trained
this morning that's different I just
wanted to get my ass beat this morning
playing basketball is like real
dangerous yes it is so fun you [ __ ]
train fighting and you said playing
basketball is way worse way basketball
get more injuries I'm talking about
playing basketball with like random
people like they're so quick to travel
you don't sound like you do mantle [ __ ]
what's going on that's rude can we let
them explain it you know what hey I'm
Anthony Lee we're gonna turn this dude
into a beast bro we're gonna turn into a
fighting machine
with this dancing [ __ ] bro like he's
gonna be good get you or something like
that bro you might be a monster that's
what I'm saying you guys can beat my
asses but I might have a quick learning
curve oh yeah real quick hey show them
that jab dude
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey there's there's there just was newly
uploaded video of that same fight what's
the backstory a few seconds prior and
they're praying together and then this
is how it starts I guess it's that
[ __ ] dad I bet you like they're
fighting verbal [ __ ] right here I want
to see the dads I got wait what
what is happening I love how none of the
kids are involved it's just adults boom
he wasn't really doing anything I bet
that dad was talking hell was he doing
probably like throughout the whole game
yeah he probably saying the racist stuff
that sucks so imagine if he was talking
all that [ __ ] they got knocked out what
if he didn't say a thing what if he
wasn't doing anything yeah my kid my kid
he was like Hey guys stop fighting stop
please and he just gets [ __ ] you see
that video though where that happened
what so there's these two guys in New
York they were fighting under a bridge
and they were scrapping yeah and then
one guy came in to break it up he got so
confused he just started beating up the
dude that was breaking it
yeah cause people kind of like there is
like a fight or flight mechanism right
like when you get involved it was hella
funny everyone's all over the place
another one that's like that too and
this guy's just chilling by the light
post and then two guys are [ __ ] going
at it and he gets confused and he starts
[ __ ] up the guy at the light bulb and
the guy's like what the [ __ ] did I do
dude that's just he's just standing
there the best version is in height
there was a video I think went like came
out like last year or something these
kids in high school are fighting in the
bathroom as most people do in high
school they start scrapping and they
start they start to throw them down and
they break through the stall and they're
just kidding [ __ ]
they're fighting oh on top of him and
he's like [ __ ] man he's like [ __ ] and
that's every High School kid's worst
nightmare you know what's better than
that one there was one in [ __ ] East
L.A there was these two Mexican kids
right and they're fighting and they're
like talking [ __ ] but one of the other
girls you could tell he doesn't want to
fight right he goes hey but not the face
only in the body
[Laughter]
they be saying that [ __ ] though like
when you start throwing down they're
like none of that kicking [ __ ] dog like
they'll [ __ ] jump you if you do that
[ __ ] dude this shit's traumatizing as a
kid to see your [ __ ] parents get
slapped bro I know dude that's the dad's
phone man he should not because I've
been to like uh kid basketball games
where the dad's like are you [ __ ]
blind rough are you and then since
they're like so keyboard Warrior ass
because they know nothing can happen
they'll scream at the ref and they just
go back to the bleachers with no
consequences and I'm like man I feel so
bad for the refs I'll tell you this like
if I had a dad that got knocked out by
the ref and the next day my dad was like
take out the trash he's like shut up
before I call the reply let me get
ripped over here
you [ __ ] nightmares you start putting
on Foot Locker [ __ ]
have you guys ever seen your parents
like get into a fight yes yeah I have
yes my dad so it's my sister's
ex-boyfriend at that time was talking
[ __ ] to like in front of my house to get
my sister's dad yeah he was like okay
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and then my dad was
like oh hell no and then they started
just kind of going at it and the whole
neighborhood came out and like it was
your dad's such a g I made her dad laugh
once in my life and he laughed so fast
he realized he was laughing he took it
away from me
doing at the Japanese barbecue spot in
Hawaii I made some type of joke he goes
ha ha
I've never been able to make him laugh
he laughed recognized me he took it from
me do you remember what you said at
least I don't know I think I was like
Asian people aren't human and he was
like
that's the truth
yeah that [ __ ] people are not human
[Music]
[Music]